um
foreign
thank you very much I am would want to
talk about super event qubits I'll get
to that but I want to talk about a
bigger generic problem well you might
even say it's a psychological problem
and let me explain that
we have these amazing computer devices
based on bits
okay and this works so well and it's so
powerful
we can abstract the bits we don't have
to think of all about Hardware anymore
and we just think about this in
conceptually manipulating information
and the degree of that abstraction is
now
such that let's say you talk to some
Silicon Valley Executives they believe
we live in a computer simulation
okay now we're physicists so we don't
believe that but that's how powerful
this abstraction is
and what I want to talk about today
and it's the problem with qubits
is that we have this psychological
thinking that we can abstract qubits in
the same way now it's great that we can
abstract two level systems and Quantum
systems as qubits
but we cannot abstract it in a way that
we're doing with classical
in particular we know fundamentally at
least at this point
that qubits have errors that's the
problem with qubits
and if you abstract away qubits which is
good for doing calculations whatever but
you want to talk about reality you want
to talk about industrial use if you
extract the way
the noise you are not talking about
qubits anymore
this is
I'm going to say this is sorcery
this these are magical qubits if you
talk about a real physical system
without talking noise
okay that's a magical qubit we're
talking about physical qubits so what
happens is when you build a qubit and
you talk about qubits you really need to
be honest about what's going on talking
about the noise how well does it work
what are all the problems
and if you don't do that you're talking
about magic you're talking about
something that maybe in some instances
that work right but if you really want
to think about building a quantum
computer
you know that that's that's not right so
don't pretend qubits are perfect
and then secondly how noisy are they
okay and
you know Anthony noises in fact
important to understand
so let me start
by saying why I think noise is very
important and why maybe there's some
magical qubits and we could take
advantage of this Quantum phenomenon
without worrying about the noise it
might actually be true okay you don't
know but I think it's very unlikely
and I want to talk first about uh I
think Drew Potter was one of the the
authors this is a kitb conference a few
months ago
queer bed efficient simulator with
Quantum tensor Networks
it is well known if you take a
a a
Quantum problem let's say a 2d correct
2D array of connected qubits
you can solve
for the quantum evolution of that very
efficiently using Quantum tensor
networks it's an approximation
but it's a pretty good approximation you
can solve that
and if you say okay let's solve that
what happens is the approximation have
having to do with this introduces some
errors let's say around one or two
percent
okay and it may depend on Problem
whatever but it's roughly that
so um so I have a conjecture here for
the nist threshold conjecture
okay
it basically says that quantum computers
and simulators can be efficiently
simulated with errors
of approximately a few percent just by
using this
okay and Hardware if you want to do
something useful
you want to be below this threshold
uh so you know the point is is if you
have a quantum computer with errors a
few percent why run it on a quantum
computer run it with the quantum tensor
Network approximation and get the answer
on your computer
that's the idea
so there's a corollary here and again
this is a conjecture I don't know if
it's right Quantum Advantage can't be
claimed with no error measurement
because how do you know if you use
quantum tensor Network or some other
clever
uh approximation you know maybe you can
get a the answer or a better answer
so I'm going to say magic cubits
if
you know Cuba it's where you haven't
measured errors it's kind of they're
magical okay you don't know how powerful
that really is
now okay that's a few percent errors if
you're lower than a few percent at least
you know roughly you can't do this
okay now I also want to talk about when
we talk about errors
it's it seems to be fairly reasonable
maybe not in all cases that we can talk
about errors being a classical so when
you talk about a real physical qubit it
has some average unitary and then
there's some errors on it which we can
talk about as a random errors in X Y or
z uh and you know poly Troy uh
phenomenon allows you kind of to do that
so it's a very simple approximation
right it wouldn't you wouldn't expect
that necessarily the case and maybe not
the case generically but generally it's
fine I see this is useful because error
probability is simple to understand and
then use
and it's easier to measure predict and
it works well why it's it's first order
algebra estimate and you can use uh
randomized compiling effectively a gauge
transformation to uh you know
effectively twirl the states so that
this is a pretty good pretty good thing
so uh and in fact we validated this
I think we need more experiments to test
if this is the case but the nice thing
at least about you know noise is that we
can consider at least the first order
approximation is a relatively simple way
so your quantum mechanics and then the
errors you know can be thought about in
the in a relatively simple way and I'll
show some data to explain that
now um you know so where are we with the
errors right now how powerful algorithms
can we do
okay so if you take classical CMOS you
have some gates there's a error per
logic gate and the number of logic gates
you can put together and yield a circuit
properly poses one over the error no
surprise so in the 1960s maybe you have
a transistor error and a thousand
transistors or so so you could do
relatively uh you know reasonable size
integration tested scale it up us okay
now those error rates are down to about
10 to 11 10 minus 11 so you can build
big big processors and get them to yield
and there's a lot of I mean this is kind
of magical what happened in 60 years
okay same thing happens for quantum
you have to make a good fabrication but
of course there's a fundamental error in
the gates quantum mechanics tells you
that
however if you look at WQ bits and
instructions on each of the W qubits at
certain times so there's a depth D the
total number of gates Is WD and that's
going to go as one over the air of the
gate roughly Maybe
three times five times if we wanted to
work a small fraction at a time but
that's basically the same thing this is
more or less the coherence time over the
gate time if everything's working right
okay so here's the punch line
what are the typical errors a Quantum
Computing systems that are being built
some of them you have no idea what the
errors are
some of them have been measured but most
of them is measured the error is about
one percent maybe two percent
let's talk about a width of 100 qubits
that's pretty interesting
if the error is 10 to minus two it WS
100 depth is one
what does depth of one mean
you can you can run programs with one
instruction set
that does not seem very useful maybe
three maybe five not very useful
okay that's a big problem in the field
now if we can get those errors down to
10 minus 310 let's say 10 minus four
even
then you can get the depth of 100 and
then you can start doing something
interesting so we really want to push
down that and of course if you get to 10
minus 3 10 minus 4 you start doing error
correction and do a bunch of interesting
things
so you know that's really something that
has to be worked on is get the errors
low
and of course if you build qubits
and if you don't measure the errors you
have no idea what you can run
and whether you can use this uh other
approximations to simulate what you're
doing you don't know that
the basic thing you have to do is
understand what your errors are to know
if you have a chance of doing something
powerful
okay so there's more it's even more
subtle than this
so I want to talk a little bit about the
strategy of measurement errors because
it's actually a little bit complicated
and and basically let me just say you
can build let's say uh you know these
individual transistor in my cell phone
that's pretty good but you don't know
that when you put a billion of these
together whether this thing is still
going to work and the engineers do a lot
of work to make sure that when you scale
it up it still is going to work right
and you have to do the same thing for
the qubits this is not not obvious that
you can do that
so for example what you can do you know
single Gates you can do some kind of
tomography you can do a two-key date
doing some kind of tomography which is
basically check that your fundamental
gates are working right that's great
people do that
but a lot of things can go wrong so for
example if you taken let's say a two
qubit you can do multiple Gates one
after each other
and then see what happens in that case
and what happens is the errors you know
get bigger and bigger because you're
doing it over and over again so that's
good to do that but it also tests the
fact that this whatever's going on here
interfere with what's going on here and
here so there can be time cross time
there can be things going on that that
messes up you need to check that
and the same thing happens when you have
a big processor you can have something
going on here some gate going on here
but does that couple to this guy right
here
and you need to do that so you have to
do simultaneous one or two gates on a
large processor to do space crust
and then what you have to do is on a big
algorithm with lots of gates
you have to check
whether you're getting this correct
answer
okay you have to check that too as in as
in a full algorithm
and I would say this is the most
important thing you have to look at the
answers coming from this or this or
whatever it is and see if they make
sense from what you did up here
right did you introduce errors
as you scaled it up
you have to compare the errors and you
have to have a system error model that
hopefully is consistent with what you
measure on individuals this is a basic
engineering concept now the reason I
bring it up
is I go to conferences and I know about
this and I ask people who are building
con and computer systems and people
aren't checking this and that may be
running a large algorithm but they have
no idea what's happening to the errors
in fact what's really worrisome to me
for the field is that they don't even
know that that's a question and that's
something they should be doing it's like
oh they never thought of it the the
company never thought of it so that's
why I go around talking about it because
if I I want to look at all what all
people are doing I need to do these
cross checks to see if things are
working right you don't know until you
measure it
so um 10 minutes good
so
what I want to do is talk about how we
actually went about measuring that and
this was actually in the quantum
Supremacy experiment uh we we did that
so you do Quantum State and process
tomography uh you do randomized
benchmarking is this is like whether you
see the full Quantum Matrix you know
it's working okay the randomized
benchmarking to figure out if the errors
are let's say compatible with this and
then you do cross entropy benchmarking
and it's very similar to randomized
benchmarking but you do it for arbitrary
Gates and what you do is get the best
fit unitary plus an error and I would
say that's a pretty useful thing for you
to know is what that is
and you can there's a lot of interesting
things you can you can do there so let
me not go into this in detail but let's
just talk about what we did for the
quantum Supremacy experiment to
illustrate all this
okay what we did is we did single qubits
all by themselves and we measure how the
state how how you do a bunch of dunks of
gates and you see how the coherence
decays and you do that on the 53 qubits
and you get a a histogram if you
integrate that histogram to get that
dotted line
and then what you do is you turn off all
these Gates
and then you do it individually on each
of those so that's instead of separate
you do it simultaneous you get the black
line here it's a little bit worse but
not too much and that's okay so that's a
good check
it's like you don't have all this
horrible crosstalk or something you do
the same thing for two Cubit Gates
and then individually
and then you run the whole thing at the
same time yeah that gets gets a little
bit worse that's a trickier date but
okay at least you know what's going on
you do the measurement sir can you
remind me what what's the app why access
on this histogram what are these numbers
of this is the y-axis so you do a
histogram and then you integrate that
histogram that's a cumulative
probability distribution so if you were
to take the derivative of this this
would kind of look like a gaussian shape
got it and it's it's just easy it's you
it's better to plot it this way
so if you want to know what the average
error is you take 50 and you you come
down there if you want to say 90 of the
gates are better than that error
so this is this is we find this a much
better way and you're not losing any
data any accuracy the data turns out I
can talk about that later okay
so how do you test this full circuit and
it's basically uh doing this cross
entropy benchmarking but this is the
basic idea when you you do this you run
uh randomly Cho known but randomly
chosen Gates this is essentially a
random number generator and you generate
all the states here
okay all to the end States however
because that's a coherent circuit some
of those states are more probable and
some are less probable just like a laser
going through frosted glass some
directions you get constructive
interference in some directions you get
destructive interference the same thing
happens here and basically what you do
is you measure these states which are
going to be the most likely States the
higher probability States and then you
run this circuit on a classical computer
maybe a supercomputer to see if actually
the state you measure where the high
probability States and you can come up
with a nice mathematical function given
by here where X is what you measure and
P is what you computed and if it's one
over two to the N this Fidelity is zero
if you have a perfect match no
decoherence at all
you get a one
and what's really interesting about this
is if you have any bit Flip or face flip
anywhere in here
that completely randomizes
this qubit speckle pattern
and the Fidelity equal to zero
completely uncorrelates it so you really
can when you measure zero and one how
zero and one it is tells you what the
percentage of time there were zero
errors in running that circuit
and of course zero errors in calibrating
it and you know transferring it over to
soon beer or whatever so it's a really
good check of your system it's a great
system check
and here's the quantum Supremacy data I
I don't have time people we've seen this
this is our data here doing the cross
entropy benchmarking and uh it goes down
exponentially as expect there's more and
more chances of errors
but the interesting thing I want to say
with this talk is the black line here
and the black line is the prediction
from the gate and measurement errors
that I showed you a couple slides ago
and that prediction in fact is just the
total fidelity
of the system is one with the Fidelity
of all the individual one and two
elements
and this is kind of amazing you have
this great
great uh agreement here
and what happens is the if the quantum
nature of this gives you the speckle
pattern this unique speckle pattern very
difficult to calculate you know it takes
a long time
but
the errors are given by a high school
statistics formula
so the errors are really simple
at least you know in this experiment but
the computation is experiment is is hard
so it's kind of nice you know you could
be and this this is this is great it
means that you can at least in this
experiment and maybe in more experiments
you have the the full power upon a
computer but you want to estimate if
it's going to work you know it's not too
hard assuming everything works of course
okay and you can show this is here's
some data of the xcb Fidelity I think
this is 12 14 qubits you have about 22
Fidelity and then you put in a facelift
that goes to zero as expect and in fact
if you put in a face flip with arbitrary
phase it follows this cosine squared
Behavior which is the prediction of the
digitization of Errors which of course
is part of what you assume to get uh
Quantum error correction working and
this is a digitization way inside the
inside of the this complicated algorithm
and yet it it still works uh properly to
think of it in this simple-minded way so
this is this is really kind of nice that
it works that way
okay so that's what I have to do about
noise but asked to talk about super
connecting two bits I don't know I'm
going to say much basically saying super
enlightened qubits work and all the
system components work
and if anything's right and I'm also
going to say the Subaru qubits are
pretty fast
20 10 29 a second date time and this is
a critical metric because when you run
some kind of algorithm you might want to
take 10 to 4 10 to 5 10 to the six
repetitions to get a low statistical
uncertainty of whatever you're measuring
and if you're you know having nanosecond
10 nanosecond time scales you can do
this
fast and then you can change it and
optimize it so making fast qubits is
really useful for really doing that
as I said here we need the lower errors
I think those everyone knows about this
in the field they're working on it I I
think it's possible to do that we all we
know the architecture right now and you
know improvements in cubic coherence has
been demonstrated we have to put it
together it's not trivial I think it can
be done though
and then people often say about okay
super deducting qubits are not very
scalable
you know I I have a plan and maybe other
people do too to scale to very large
size in a reasonable manner I think it's
possible to do that of course we have to
show that the first thing the course is
to work on lowering the errors making
these
um um making these better cubics better
physical qubits
okay uh so
if if you're upon a computer has uh you
okay you want to build a quantum
computer you need to measure the errors
you should be less than one or two
percent
to actually start to doing something
useful and then I'm saying that the
error is below 0.1 percent or so is for
interesting deep algorithms error
correction that's really our Target
we've known this for a while but we
really have to hit that
um and I also want to say just
you know measuring the T1 T2 or
measuring one or two Cubit dates is nice
but you have to measure system errors
and compare with your error budget if
you aren't doing that
don't know what's going on
with a Quantum supremacist experiment
that's the reason why I did it at Google
as I wanted to know that China has
reproduced that
I don't think anyone else has done that
in the west that's a real problem
and yeah we really have to do that and
and to just to conclude this
the reason I'm going around talking
about the problem with few bits
is that if we want to be around
talking about Quantum Computing in five
or ten years we need to bet make better
qubits because if we make better qubits
we don't make better qubits and what we
have right now there's not really a
reason for this field to exist
if we want to have a successful field we
want to do something useful
we have to improve the qubits and I hope
some people here are are want to invest
in that in that future this is something
that I personally am thinking about
really focusing my effort how to
understand that make good qubits make it
scalable and I feel very confident we
can do that but it takes a lot of effort
and the problem is is you don't get a
nice nature signs paper out of it okay
this is this is the this is the
psychological problem but I think if you
do that
well then then uh instead of uh you know
picking the low-hanging fruit you're
then planting the orchard to do many
many interesting things so please if
people are interested please uh please
work on this it's really important
now with that thank you very much
[Applause]
for a great time
what are some ideas to approve the
coherence time
so
um
if it was a simple answer
someone would have done it already
okay
and I think there's a variety of things
going on and the problem is is there
more than one thing going on at the same
time you work on one of them you know it
doesn't get better so you don't know if
you're on the right track
so there's there's um there's several
things you have to work on
um
so a lot of these ideas are kind of in
the literature already but if you
haven't been really focused on I'm going
to say it mostly just takes a lot of
time doing very careful experiments to
make sure that you can really ever
budget all of this and figure it out
okay the big things are uh you know you
know a two nanometer interface of a more
basil silicon dioxide between the metal
and the substrate absolutely kills the
the coherence we know that people are
working on it uh and as an example uh
you know there's also Cosmic arrays
there's a whole list of things you have
to get right
I I think it I think you just have to
work on this very carefully and you have
to learn how to Fab it in a reliable way
so uh the one or two percent error uh is
for example we have angle errors because
we have the the qubits that going around
in the complex plane right uh the um but
an angle error of one or two percent uh
gives an amplitude error of cosine of
let's say one degree which is like 10
minus four which is much better so uh
well the angle errors are more like you
know um
they aren't are they aren't uh one
percent it it's uh it's ten percent it's
gonna give you one percent
exactly uh so uh what you're saying is
that uh the Anglers of ten percent
there'll be one-fifth of a variety
that's how bad it is is that what you're
saying so what uh well 10 degree error
is one one uh 10 degree is 10 degrees is
um yeah Arabians with a 660 degrees so
that's one sixth and I think that's
there's a factor of two so that's one
tenths that's about that's about uh
that's about one percent if I did the
calculation I I don't calculate in
public very well